[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de france 3 franche comté pour
une nouvelle soirée spéciale élections
municipales avec au programme ce soir
deux débats besançon puis vesoul
on commence par besançon avec six
invités sur le plateau tout d'abord eric
alauzet député de la république en
marche
il conduit la liste lrm modem anne
vignot d'europe écologie les verts
elle est à la tête d'une liste ee lv ps
pcf génération ludovic fagots qui est
conseiller départemental et l'air à ses
côtés jacques richir des ti du
rassemblement national
en face se trouve claire arnoux de la
france a soumises et puis alexandra
cordier ancien référente de la
république en marche pour le doubs elle
n'a pas obtenu l'investiture nrm et
conduit une liste divers centres
quelques minutes avant la fin de ce
débat david mal de france bleu
interviendra à son tour pour vous poser
mesdames et messieurs quelques questions
je vous propose un premier tour de table
l'ordre de réponse a été tiré au sort et
c'est anne vignot qui commence ce débat
anne vignot c'est sur votre lit ce que
se trouve le plus de sortants de la
majorité de jean louis fousseret
assumez-vous le bilan de ces six
dernières années de mandat
moi je parle toujours du futur on est
vraiment ça tombe mal puisque ma
question c'est sur les six ans qui
viennent de se passer
on a effectivement le la chance avec
besoins sont par nature d'avoir réuni la
gauche parce que la gauche c'est la
culture de besançon la gauche et
l'écologie
et comme je voulais que nous montions
une liste pour porter haut et fort
l'écologie dans toutes nos politiques je
voulais que nous ayons la possibilité
d'avoir le plus de personnes possibles
cohérente par rapport à ce projet là et
il me semblait nécessaire que la gauche
s'unissent sur cette liste là eric
alauzet vous vous êtes beaucoup battu
pour avoir l'investiture la république
en marche
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être un poids
cette appartenance au parti présidentiel
est ce que vous regrettez d'avoir cette
étiquette je me projette
dans l'avenir aussi aussi je pense que
ce que des bisontins attendent de nous
c'est qu'on leur dise le projet que l'on
veut pour besançon pour leur vie
quotidienne pour la place de besançon
pour la place de besançon dans la grande
région le poids de besançon on a perdu
le statut de capitale régionale énergie
là-dessus j'ai rassemblé beaucoup de
monde effectivement la république en
marche les modèles beaucoup de sociétés
civiles sont les plus nombreux on va du
centre gauche au centre
quelques élus de centre-droit et
l'écologie est très présente dans notre
dans l'autre alexandra cordier vous
intervenez en troisième position alors
quelle est votre légitimité pour être
candidates si ce n'est d'avoir été une
proche collaboratrice de jean louis
fousseret le maire sortant il est
d'ailleurs sur votre liste et d'avoir
son soutien vous parlais justement de
cette expérience en mairie donc j'ai
travaillé pendant plus de 10 ans mais
rien vous voulez bien parler du passé
voilà voilà
et donc cette expérience me permet
justement de présenter une candidature
crédible et c'est une candidature de
rassemblement d'ouverture c'est une
liste sans étiquette
je reviens par rapport à ce que vous
avez dit en introduction une liste
divers sens donc c'est bien une liste
sans étiquette indépendante qui a le
soutien de jean-louis fousseret
c'est vrai et qui réunit des hommes et
des femmes qui ont qui sont compétents
claire arnoux alors vous mettez souvent
en avant une liste composée de citoyens
et de citoyennes
vous êtes à la tête souvent de ce genre
de liste
est ce que vous êtes devenue quasi une
professionnelle de la politique petit à
petit est ce que filme professionnels de
la politique je dis que l'asie je pense
que c'est autour de cette table je suis
la seule à ne pas être le plus éloigné
d'une professionnelle de la politique
puisque je suis à rendre une militante
et je n'ai pas mandat électif et
contrairement par exemple aux trois
personnes qui viennent de parler avant
j'ai rien à voir avec la mairie
précédente
et cette liste elle est citoyenne elle
est née notamment de militants et de
militantes qui pendant six ans on était
dans l'opposition agents du fousseret à
ce mr macro nist et qui a connu une
dérive nous considère que cette ville de
besançon a connu une dérive droitière
avec un certain nombre d'éléments qui
ont été choquants pour les bisontines et
les bisontins de l'arrêté anti mendicité
des projets d'urbanisme délirant donc
voilà cette liste est né de cet endroit
là
ludovic fagots des républicains on vous
attendait comme ce qu'en dit
da sur la commune de saône vous avez une
maison et puis à besançon on attendait
plutôt jacques grosperrin
le sénateur qui a déjà été candidat et
d'ailleurs finalement c'est vous est ce
que vous êtes le plan b des républicains
non je ne pense pas aujourd'hui vous
faites référence à une maison à ce qu'on
a acheté avec mon épouse il ya déjà onze
ans maintenant
quand j'étais adjoint et j'ai été muté
sur le collège de sono que mon
appartement est aussi ici sur sur
besançon c'est pas un plan b je crois
que c'est aussi l'avenir de la politique
aujourd'hui de pouvoir faire confiance à
une nouvelle génération qui s'inscrit
vraiment dans une dynamique nouvelle
pour apporter de nouveaux visages et de
nouvelles énergies et à nouveau projet
aussi pour pour le territoire
donc on est vraiment dans cette dans
cette dynamique là et c'est dans cette
tendance vraiment que je que je
m'inscris parce qu'on a des talents très
importants et un potentiel énorme sur le
territoire bisontin qu'il faut faire
valoir et en tout cas c'est tout le sens
de mon engagement
chaque crise hier des ti vous vous êtes
maire sortant de tressan d'une petite
commune à côté de baume les dames
vous voilà candidats à besançon et vous
êtes le seul représentant du
rassemblement national engagé dans une
grande ville de franche comté est ce
qu'il ya énormément de pression sur vos
épaules
côté pas du tout je lui ai tout à fait
décontractée je suis je suis ici avec
grand bonheur pour faire changer besoins
sont à porter un projet nouveau
je suis effectivement j'ai pas été en
responsabilité sur la commune bisontine
j'y vis j'y travaille je les connais
parfaitement
j'ai un réseau voient la région nous
avons dans la liste changeant besançon
des solutions et nous allons les a
portées et je pense que les bisontins y
répondrons favorablement
trois autres candidats sont également en
lice dimanche pour le premier tour
karim bois soul n'a pas souhaité
profiter du temps de parole que nous
leurs huit proposions mais nichols riez
de lutte ouvrière et jean philippe
allenbach du mouvement franche-comté
explique les motivations de leur
candidature notre combat c'est quand des
hommes et des femmes qui ont cette
conscience d'appartenir à cette classe
qui fait ont marché dans la société la
classe ouvrière et surtout qui en sont
fiers pendant ces élections nous
afférentes en notre colère contre toutes
les mesures anti-ouvrières menée par les
capitalistes la réforme contre les
retraites
la réforme du chômage la précarité la
misère les licenciements secs comme mais
ce qui nous attend et notre programme
justement c'est pas un programme le cas
c'est un programme de lutte qui
permettent aux travailleurs de se
défendre mais surtout de pouvoir mener
leur bagarre jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout
de leurs revendications
parce que nous nous sommes communiste
révolutionnaire et nous pensons que n'y
a que les travailleurs qui pourront
changer leur sort et surtout ils vont
devront compter que sur eux mêmes parce
que personne ne le fera à leur place
la première chose que je voudrais dire
c'est pousser un coup de gueule contre
france 3 qui ne m'a pas invité au grand
débat en accordant seulement 40 secondes
pour donner mon programme
au prétexte y avait pas assez de chaises
argument imparable on en convient donc
la première mesure que je prendrais si
chimères c'est de vous offrir des
chaises pour que vous puissiez enfin
invité tout le monde au débat fallait en
faire des débats vraiment démocratique
la deuxième chose c'est ce qui me tient
à coeur
sauvé besançon du déclin la population
baisse commerce
sarr est bon elle est en déclin et donc
pour sauver la ville de netanya qu'une
solution de ses plus grandes son statut
de capitale régionale à part entière ce
qui passe par rendre la franche comté
aux francs comtois
je ferai donc après faire un don à cette
fin pour le premier thème de ce débat
c'est la sécurité qui s'imposent ou
plutôt l'insécurité
aujourd'hui encore des coups de feu ont
été tirés à planoise
cette semaine dimanche soir une
fusillade a causé la mort d'une personne
en a blessé une autre ces derniers mois
ont été marqués par des événements
graves à planoise planoise un quartier
qui compte plus de vingt mille habitants
avec des fusillades sur règlement de
comptes à propos de trafic de drogue
alors je propose un premier tour de
table et je vous propose avoue jacques
richard ditty donc d'entamer ce débat
sur la sécurité
parce que quand même la sécurité en
général c'est votre flux de commerce
vous au rassemblement national ce n'est
alors concrètement qu'est ce que vous
proposez
alors concrètement ce que nous proposons
nous proposons l'armement l'étal de la
police municipale bien évidemment nous
sommes les seuls à la proposer depuis de
manière récurrente une hausse de 20% de
la police eux en tenue
aussi nous proposons une la création
d'une brigade canine des transports nous
proposons aussi un numéro d'appel proxim
sécurité où les gens peuvent appeler de
manière anonyme pour faire constater une
incivilité ou ou un problème ou un
problème récurrent de d'insécurité au
plus près de leurs de leur quotidien
nous on va déjà peut-être faire un tour
de table justement sur cette histoire
d'armement de la police municipale on
est bien d'accord sur mon étal un
armement ne l'est-elle savez que c'est
un armement fait pour tuer sûr on est
bien on est bien d'accord sur le mot
exactement exactement quand je vois au
jeu quand je vois le quotidien et
l'actualité dramatique nous étions cet
après-midi parce qu'on a je veux dire on
a distribué des tracts en était au
milieu de la population sous sous les
toners de feu ça fait ça fait quand même
une drôle d'impression
madame arnould vous armement de la
police municipale vous en dites quoi
qu'est ce que vous proposez pour la
sécurité c'est pas vraiment une surprise
dans notre camp notre camp politique on
est contre l'armement de la police
municipale je vais commencer d'abord par
adresser mes condoléances et ma
sympathie à la famille la victime ou si
la caf qui était un jeune homme est
rappelé que c'est que ces drames là qui
endeuillent des quartiers et qui touche
particulièrement les quartiers les plus
populaires de notre ville et notamment
ici le quartier de planoise
donc je vais commencer déjà par poser ça
je vais rappeler aussi que le on est là
face à planoise à un cas très
particulier qui est du grand banditisme
une guerre de territoire pour du trafic
de drogue et que ça c'est le rôle de la
police nationale et c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on a le préfet qui intervient qu on a
des enquêtes de la police judiciaire et
que en fait ça c'est le rôle de la
police nationale et qu'il faut pas
saisir prétexte de ces drames pour
parler d'un autre débat quel armement de
la police municipale parce que ce n'est
pas le rôle de la police municipale que
de lutter contre le grand banditisme et
je voudrais qu'on parle de la sécurité
et de la sûreté qui est un droit
de manière plus générale est un peu plus
englobante la sécurité la sûreté
cinglante tout un ensemble de problèmes
on va déjà faire un tout un tour de
table
cette question avec anne vignot vous
l'armement de la police municipale pour
ou contre moi j'ai dit depuis le début
qu'il n'était pas d'accord
il n'était pas du tout adaptée
d'envisager une solution à la crise dans
laquelle nous sommes
nous sommes face à du banditisme la
criminalité et du coup on a besoin de
grands professionnels enquêteurs
renseignements généraux les personnes
qui interviennent fortement on voit
aujourd'hui la berri qui est intervenu
en fin qui est intervenu hier et qui a
mis quinze personnes en garde à vue on a
besoin effectivement de nombreuses
effectif
alors donc vous vous dites police
nationale or c'est très simple moi je
dis que si l'état ne colle ne fait pas
son travail c'est à dire que
elle ne va pas mettre tout ce qu'il faut
pour protéger la population
j'irai en recours contre l'état parce
qu'il ya un article 73 de la
constitution qui dit que l'état se doit
d'assurer en continu la protection de
nous obsède dire que si vous êtes maire
fin mars la vous attaquez déjà l'état là
dessus je dis que dès à présent l'état a
fini par répondre à la demande qui était
fait et par les habitants et par nous
mêmes sur l'importance d'augmenter les
effectifs d'augmenter les moyens en
humain et d'équipements et aujourd'hui
on voit que ça ne sera pas suffisant
jusqu'à une guerre qui s'est déclenchée
et on est très content qu'il ait eu
cette intervention
mais on aura besoin d'avoir une présence
forte et on continue combien de
personnes en plus rapide nouveau 40
personnes 9,40 points
alexandra cordier ou armements au
parlement
ma compte tenu du contexte car j'observe
comme tous les bisontins que les choses
se sont véritablement aggravé l'armement
évidemment on est pour
car c'est un moment donné faut que ça
cesse il ya de gros problèmes à besançon
les bisontins doivent retrouver leur
tranquillité c'est bien normal de
répondre à ces questions quand vous êtes
d'accord avec aunisiens des ti du
rassemblement national
oui par moments létale par contre
d'accord maintenant par contre il faudra
un petit peu qu'on parle de quels types
d'armements et là je serai curieuse
effectivement d'entendre mes collègues
sur ce sujet est ce que ce seront des
armes type sig sauer 22 ou là là nous
avons affaire à une spécialiste ou qui
ces armes sont utilisées par la police
nationale
ou alors un autre calibre le 38 spécial
là je pense qu'il faut il faut en parler
parce que ça demande de la formation
également on finit le tour de table
ludovic magaud armement de la police
municipale armement indéniablement de la
police municipale on a toujours porté
nous depuis depuis 2014 parce
qu'aujourd'hui vraiment la violence a
vraiment évolué et aujourd'hui la
situation n'est plus du tout sous
contrôle sur le territoire bisontins et
pour la sécurité il faut du courage et
de l'énergie
et j'en ai par rapport à cela j'en ai
par rapport à cela et aujourd'hui je
serai le maire de la sécurité des
bisontines et des bisontins mais de
toutes les sécurités des plus petites
incivilités jusqu'aux éléments
événement tragique qu'on a pu vivre ces
derniers temps parce qu'aujourd'hui en
face de nos familles et en face de nos
policiers municipaux
ce sont des armes de guerre ce sont des
armes de guerre et je voudrais dire
vraiment et les policiers venus ici pour
même si vous les armes et ils sont
obligatoirement formés et ont recruté
ils sont recrutés ils sont formés et
sont armés ils et services à un coût
tout ça c'est un coup mais vous savez un
manurhin puisque vous faites référence à
certains certaines armes le manurhin
coûte 600 euros
quand vous avez un pistolet à plusieurs
en formation pour fort phoneo autant
autant l'utiliser police notant qu'un
pistolet à impulsions électriques qui
coûte qui coûte 500 euros
aujourd'hui on va être là dessus moi je
m'engage parce que je me suis mobilisé
durant durant ce mandat on va revenir
mais moi je me suis fait que seuls élus
autour de cette table du conseil
municipal à m'être battu auxerre du
conseil municipal pour pouvoir protéger
la population à bisontine votre armement
les terres les poires et pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que nos policiers
municipaux et des moyens d'agir sur le
territoire à cause je m'appelle pas
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui non mais je
m'appelle du deuxième wagon et je suis
engagée dans l'élection municipale
république et et nous les parties que je
vous ai pas coupé monsieur regardez
simplement pour par rapport à cela
moi les élus qui sont dans la majorité
sortante et y en a quelques-uns ici
autour de la table on va justement
toutes les vallées mesure va se tourner
vers eric alauzet doc est dans la
majorité municipale sortante député la
république en marche
vous vous dites que maintenant que vous
êtes pour l'armement de la police
municipale pourquoi vous avez changé
d'avis parce que quand vous étiez chez
les verts s'étaient pas du tout votre
opinion politique déjà c'est un sujet un
peu interdit mais au-delà de ça a servi
ou chez les verts dit d'en discuter
chez les verts ou à la guerre de la
majorité les deux les deux ânes ont
commencé mais le sujet c'est d'avoir les
grands les yeux grands ouverts sur la
réalité de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
dans nos quartiers
mais visiblement les gérants tous
d'accord la blague donc nos concitoyens
n'en peuvent plus ils se sentent en
insécurité discuter avec une maman il ya
quelques jours qui me dit cinq minutes
tu es rue de picardie un mois des coups
de feu mardi c'est planant à 16 heures
c'était à 16h05 avant j'étais avec ma
fille ni un policier municipal aurait pu
se trouver là au milieu en ronde en
faisant ce travail d'îlotage normal
peut-être que des délinquants décrit
leur appui
il aurait pu faire une rencontre on lui
aurait dit mais surtout cache toi
surtout cache toi c'est pas avec ton
bâton de défense que tu vas pouvoir
faire quoi que ce soit je ne sais pas ce
qui aurait pu se passe il se serait
trouvé sur le le devant le il aurait pu
servir de cible vous reconnaissez qu'il
ya un échec de la municipalité c'est ce
que nos policiers municipaux vont devoir
tous genres réussi son comptable les
élus les policiers mousse aux bulldozers
évoluer dans leur mission et c'est ça
qui me fait évoluer ils vont devoir
travailler la nuit ils vont devoir
travailler avec les policiers nationaux
ni vont devoir travailler beaucoup plus
fortement sur les incivilités on peut
pas les envoyer dans ces circonstances
là pour s'en être en situation de se
défendre
déjà de se défendre en premier est de ne
pas servir de cible ce n'est plus un
mythe c'est une réalité faut regarder la
réalité telle politique ici seulement
pour mieux nous défendre mais il faudra
qu'on reparle de leur mission et moi je
voudrais le coup ça coûte cher quand on
est les seuls à avoir chiffré la
politique sécuritaire et la sécurité à
besançon combien parents ou combien même
les 20 millions sur le mandat à 20
millions d'investissements 20 millions
sur six ans de 16 ans vous avez des 3
millions voilà vous avez vous avez
maintenant c'est l'habitude de la city
se mange pas de fonction mais ils vont
dérouler un 20 millions d'euros non mais
d'investissement font que jamais sa
morale et en investissement à ce qu'elle
ait peu de vaisselle n'est pas
l'investissement on est d'accord
les investissements sur la sécurité
quand vous parlez de l'armement à celles
d'investissement un an quand vous parlez
la vidéo protection
c'est de l'armement quentin et une
brigade canine c'est de l'armement je
suis désolé ça c'est tous des mots que
vous connaissez pas parce que
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on paye on paye
le laisser-aller et le laxisme des
majorités aider des oppositions monsieur
fagots des oppositions d'hier d'hier et
d'avant-hier voilà aujourd'hui le
résultat de ce qu'on voit à besançon
c'est du laxisme
vous êtes tous comptables autour de
cette table de ce qui se passe à bord de
ce qui est dit ici si vous voulez vous
êtes non la portée et je les portais
durant durant ce mandat je n'ai pas
entendu les élus de la majorité se
prononcer sur les propositions que l'on
apporté pendant pendant six ans et
madame vigneault aujourd'hui il faut
sortir vraiment de cet angélisme
on n'attrape pas les délinquants que le
simple maintenant attendez
on assez bas les délinquants vraiment
avec défile à lyon ou encore des pistes
audio disent allez vous avez toujours
d'une solution très nous aujourd'hui je
vous écouterai 5 je vous ai vraiment
écouté dans votre prise de parole je
crois qu'on va essayer de rester là et
donc nous ait recruté formé et armé nos
politiques les 'minutes' compte bien
monsieur le vent et un doublement au
sein de la plongée et un double mandat
police municipale pour porter à santenay
policiers municipaux cèdent déploiement
où il y en a une ça quand tu as
exactement s'est aussi déployée la
vidéoprotection et c'est de revoir c'est
de revoir les missions de notre police
municipale
aujourd'hui pour soi on est vraiment
dans le maintien de la tranquillité
publique et laisser la place à la police
nationale de pouvoir lutter contre la
criminalité et si vous voulez un chiffre
parce que nous aussi on l'a fait
chiffrer
on est entre 2 millions et 2 millions et
demi d'euros par an par an la parole à
claire arnaud de me disais tout à
l'heure quelle est la nôtre l'art moment
je suis merci de me redonner la parole
je suis vraiment attristé en fait que
ces événements est dramatique servent de
prétextes prétexte politicien je suis
désolé de vous le dire à développer ces
mesures là et je pense que vous pouvez
tout à fait moi je vous reconnais le
droit de développer la nécessité de
l'armement de la police municipale mais
s'il vous plaît ne prenait pas prétexte
de ces événements là parce que là on est
face à du grand banditisme et je suis
désolé quand vous dites que armée la
police municipale ça va régler les
conflits de guerres de drogue c'est faux
c'est faux là on est sûr c'est le préfet
qui s'occupe de ça c'est le rôle de
l'état c'est le rôle de l'état et je
vais terminer sur autre chose parce que
la sécurité c'est pas que ça
je suis désolée la sécurité c'est pas
que l'armement de la police municipale
la sécurité c'est toute une politique
est là où je vais être d'accord avec
vous c'est que la sûreté est un droit
c'est un droit constitutionnel et c'est
un droit constitutionnel depuis 1789
auparavant c'était assuré qu'à une élite
aristocrates ou bourgeoise et c'est la
déclaration des droits de l'homme qui a
fait de ce droit un droit pour tous et
toutes donc on est aussi très attaché à
la sécurité et on a aussi un programme
sur la sécurité qui se base notamment
sur des mesures sur des mesures de
renforcement de demander le renforcement
de la police nationale ça c'est un
malfrat toussaint je le répète on le
fait que nous on se permet quelques jeux
termine parce que je vous ai laissé le
débat d'entre vous mais on a aussi
d'autres mesures et moi je voudrais
aussi avancé d'autres mesures puisque on
a aussi un programme sur ce point là on
le veut notamment le retour des cours
pendant la nuit qui est un service qui
était essentielle à la vie des quartiers
et qui était essentielle à la sécurité
la nuit dans le centre qui a été
supprimée par la municipalité précédente
on veut dans le quartier de planoise
remettre de l'humain à remettre des
liens il ya tout un ensemble
d'incivilité nous vous parlais justement
qui sont dans les immeubles hlm et nous
on propose notamment le retour des
concierges qui ont été supprimés on va
on va laisser l'ensemble sélection de
ratio cordier s'il vous plaît et après
ce sera à vous et eric alauzet alors moi
ce qui m'interesse effectivement c'est
la sécurité des bisontins
nous sommes favorable aussi à une police
armée pour déjà assurer la sécurité et
des fonctionnaires municipaux et aussi
celle des bisontins je mettrai juste un
petit bémol sur cette course à
l'armement immédiat vous savez on peut
pas mettre une arme létale tout de suite
dans les mains de tout le monde
il ya des temps de formation alors
beaucoup de nos policiers municipaux
sont déjà formés mais pas tous
donc il faudra prendre du temps aussi
par rapport à ça et pour avoir travaillé
au cabinet je peux vous dire qu'il ya
des procédures pour équiper quelqu'un
d'une arme qui peut tuer donc il faut
absolument aussi travailler ça dans un
dans le cadre d'un projet de service
avec les policiers municipaux
regardez aussi les armes qui veulent
utiliser ce travail aussi avec eux et ça
je trouve fois séparés de leur dire
aujourd'hui la eric alauzet donc est ce
que la municipalité s'est engagée dans
l'erreur ces derniers temps pourquoi
vous avez changé d'avis
combien ça coûte ce que vous vous
proposez 29 où la situation a surtout
évolué et les débats qu'on a eu les uns
et les autres
les positions que j'ai moi-même prise
madame arnould ne datent pas de cette
période de deux mois avec les écouter
gentiment fait la même chose ce sera
bien mieux
bien donc mes positions date de bien
avant les fusillades et j'ai expliqué
les raisons de mon engagement est de mon
évolution
c'est pour le travail nocturne ça n'a
rien à voir écrit fusillade c'est pour
travailler sur les incivilités c'est
pour travailler avec la police nationale
en second rideau bien évidemment chacun
a ses missions il ne fait pas semblant
de ne pas le savoir
donc ça n'a rien à voir quand vite que
votre ep on prend le prétexte de ces
fusillades par une position c'est faux
alors soit vous ne le savez pas c'est
bien vous êtes honnête soit vous le
savez très bien et c'est vous qui
instrumentalise et les événements
actuels pour faire des procès
d'intention
gilles bien qu'il faut maintenant que
les policiers on va donner les foules
sur date de l'automne bien je pouvais
pas laisser passer ça j'ai lu vos
communiqués de presse avec attention et
vous lis est ce que je passe à planoise
avec la question de l'armement de la
police municipale or ces deux choses
différentes et je leur ai déjà dit ma
d'assurer bien armada marne où vous
l'avez déjà dit encore un mot madame
vigneault et on passe au thème suivant
oui je crois qu'on mélange différents
dégradation de la situation dans
planoise et dans toute la ville
il faut dire aussi que c'est dans toute
la ville et que on a face à une
augmentation de l'économie parallèle
besoin de la police nationale la police
municipale
elle doit revoir son sa mission et c'est
la première chose que je ferai quand je
serai maire c'est retravailler sa
mission surtout animé des cellules de
veille
il faut accompagner la vie des quartiers
il faut être très présent il faut
observer et être en capacité
d'intervenir très vite en particulier
sur la jeunesse qui parfois se fait
happer par ses réseaux internationaux
d'ailleurs merci madame donc deuxième
thème de cette émission la dynamisation
de la ville vous aura pas échappé de
comme on le disait que besançon a fait
la une de l'actualité nationale dans les
pages faits divers une notoriété dont
les bisontins se serait bien passée la
notoriété c'est une valeur en forte
chute depuis que besançon a perdu son
titre de capitale régionale c'est le
fait marquant depuis les dernières
élections municipales
donc besançon a perdu son titre de
capitale régionale au profit de dijon
lors de la fusion bourgogne franche
comté
alors comment lui rendre du dynamisme le
lustre d'antan je vais d'abord vous
posez la question à vous ludovic fagots
qu'est ce que vous faites si vous êtes
maire pour rendre besoins sont
attractives attrayante et dynamique
aujourd'hui l'attractivité de nos
territoires et leurs veaux tout et c'est
comme ça qu'on le porte avec l'équipe de
besançon maintenant touristique
commercial économique et aussi
d'événementiel touristique c'est se
former ces fameux projet port citadelle
que l'on porte
puisqu'on veut faire aussi notre ville
un vecteur de développement économique
par le biais du tourisme avec cette
liaison coeur de ville les prés de vaux
et la liaison la citadelle et ouvrir la
sida elle vous rendez compte qu'en
disant qu'on est inscrit au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco nous n'avons pas
pris un visiteur on est passé de 270
mille visiteurs il ya dix ans à 270
milles visiteurs
aujourd'hui ça c'est un élément phare et
on a vraiment un rendez vous à ne pas
manquer avec ce projet d'envergure
ensuite c'est l'animation l'animation de
notre ville il faut que ça rayonne est
un petit tour de table et bien sûr
l'animation je termine simplement notre
marché de noël regardez à un petit peu
le rayonnement faible rayonnement que
peut avoir notre marché de noël et à
falloir repenser à cela et faire aussi
aujourd'hui que ça s'ouvre avec le mois
de la musique que l'on veut porter sur
la rentrée de septembre en lien bien sûr
avec les acteurs ressources alexandra
cordier concernant le tourisme les
transports aussi bon on va rester sur le
tourisme vous proposez vous c'est très
original
un téléphérique pour la citadelle à 50
millions d'euros pour la vois quelque
chose de si gigantesque non avec mes
colistiers avec notre liste ensemble on
souhaite faire en sorte que notre ville
continue à grandir continue à investir
donc effectivement depuis plusieurs
semaines on a porté cette ambition de
réaliser trois grands projets la
reconversion de l'ancien hôpital saint
jacques
premier point la réalisation d'un
nouveau mode de transport
un transport par câble donc un
téléphérique urbain qui relie la partie
haute et la partie basse de besançon et
un stadium vélodrome
puisqu'on considère aussi que ce ça fait
partie des attentes des bisontins
d'avoir un nouvel équipement multisports
dans lequel également pourrait se
produire des concerts à une vidéo je
vous ai vus prendre des notes
qu'est ce qui vous fait tiquer c'est
saint jacques et saint jacques
moi si on me dit que c'est un nouveau
projet à vue
avancée de ce dossier la bombe enquêtes
d'opinion rien qu'a fait en fait on est
à faire on a quand même choisi revoir
les personnes qui vont travailler sur ce
dossier on a un vendu un certain nombre
d'éléments de face et pas nous
d'ailleurs c'est le chu qui est là vendu
et le n'est pas bon ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que je suis très surprise
mais c'est comme le téléphérique
j'ai été les fers et qu'il est sur le
modèle de toulouse il a commencé à 50
millions il a fini à 80 voilà on en
rediscutera peut-être sur 16 ans on n'a
pas l'habitude de livrer les projets qui
dépassent ces enveloppes estimé voilà
donc en attendant entre 50 et 80
millions je pense qu'il ya quelque chose
d'intéressant à savoir et puis on en
reparlera je vous exposerai le projet
que moi que je porte a dit oh vous avez
la parole gagner là d'accord est bien
assez simple déjà on a la chance d'avoir
une ville universitaire et je tiens à
souligner d'ailleurs qu'un certain
nombre de réformes met en difficulté
cette université et que j'espère que du
coup les personnes qui me disent vouloir
accompagner notre ville pour qu'elle
soit rayonnante et bien ils sauront
faire les bons choix pour accompagner ne
peut être remettre en cause les réformes
qui sont mises en qui met en difficulté
la recherche
nous avons énormément de on a vingt
mille étudiants
on a énormément de chercheurs c'est un
savoir faire ça c'est vous c'est là
dessus que vous voulez vous appuyer pour
le rayonnement de la ville
c'est quand même une personne sur cinq
est à besançon c'est un des éléments qui
doit être confortée on a un chu qui en
très grande difficulté aussi pour des
raisons aussi de choix politiques qui
ont été faits je tiens à le dire ça
faisait partie des éléments structurants
de notre ville par contre on a vraiment
peut-être perdu la notion de le titre de
capitale régionale 2
comment dire de la région de
franche-comté mais par contre on a gardé
plein de capital un capital de
patrimoine & capital naturel un capital
aussi industriel on a un tissu
d'activité et que nous on va faire
traîner un petit peu la parole oui mais
c'est juste pour l'attractivité de alors
écoutez bien vous allez beaucoup plus
sobre envoyé ça c'est le titre de notre
métier notre liste la sobriété
alors donc nous on fera pas un port
je suis plus trop quoi ni un
téléphérique machin ni un rayonnement de
la ville par l'éducation nationale et
enfin bref nous nous pour nous ce sera
la construction d'un nouveau palais des
congrès centre d'affaires aux hawks ont
voilà au coeur des mobilités comme un
trait d'union et oxo faut dire que c'est
là où se trouve la gare tgv
merci de le préciser au coeur des
mobilités entre la gare tgv et
l'autoroute on veut redonner la
concession autoroutière entre marche au
héron shoah à la ville de manière à ce
qu'on ait un tronçon comme une deuxième
rocade gratuite et desservir cette
partie de la ville de manière à ce
qu'ils ont et une attractivité
économique
ce nouveau centre on peut faire
cinquante mille mètres carrés couverts
avec un parc des congrès à l'allemande
vous savez les sobriété ça veut dire
combien de millions ah bah écoutez je
pense que on est aussi désolé je lui
demande de chiffrer vos projets 11 ans à
15 millions d'euros d'investissements
ont été le terrain y est il n'est pas
très prisé donc le foncier c'est pas un
problème c'est simplement une histoire
de construction se laver les mains
oui c'est de la foreign exactement c'est
de la forêt c'est de la forêt dont les
lyonnais mais il a été calé parfaitement
massacrés par le tgv déjà eu de l'effet
et une déclaration d'utilité publique là
dessus ça fait pas on en trouve que ça a
plus de sens d'implanter ce type
d'équipement le palais de congrès en
coeur de ville dans le projet est donc
urgent au coeur de ville où on ne
circule pas vous m'expliquerez comment
un pôle justement va parler des
transports tout allait bien
eric alauzet pour l'attractivité de la
ville le sujet il est crucial c'est la
place de besançon son poids dans la
région son identité sa reconnaissance au
loin et donc l'activité touristique
commercial le centre et il ne va pas
très bien et économique j'ai quatre
cibles précises
j'en ai une qui autour du patrimoine
naturel extraordinaire
la boucle du doubs et de ces collines
nimetz ni nancy ni strasbourg ni dijon
dont cette valeur ajoutée et donc de
développer du sport nature autour de ce
patrimoine extraordinaire un terrain de
jeu fantastique avec un projet qu'on
appelle totem quête auprès de vos quêtes
une base de sports et d'activités y
voilà vous laisser autant de temps pour
développer les trois autres historique
et culturel du centre ville du haut de
boucles pour lier la boucle à la
citadelle avec une cheminement qui soit
agrémenté qui soit facile c'est très
important que les touristes les
visiteurs haye
de la boucle au centre ville du centre
ville à la citadelle de la citadelle à
la boue pour faire vivre le centre-ville
et non pas d'aller les envoyer sur un
téléphérique au des télécabines qui sont
complètement excentré qui feront partir
les nourrit pourtant l'université l'ird
extrêmement importante avec les
développements industriels dans les
microtechniques dans la santé et aussi
les deux nouveautés mises qu'on veut
créer sur le développement durable et
sur le numérique et enfin pour terminer
besançon ville de la musique on a des
talents extraordinaires à la fois pour
nos enfants
tous les enfants chantent et en haut de
la pyramide une salle de musique un
auditorium à saint jacques en faisant
rencontrer les demi finales par rapport
à ça et quand même mieux que la copie
parce que je m'aperçois quand même dans
les propos que vous venez de d'évoquer
que vous parlez grossièrement du projet
port citadelle qu'on a développé déjà
depuis un certain temps vous parler du
projet thémis numérique qu'on a
développé déjà en présentant le projet
depuis un certain temps donc enfin moi
je tiens quand même à pourrait donner la
parole à la copie elle est quand même un
peu pâle par rapport à l'original vers
arnaud vous avez déjà beaucoup de temps
d'avant sauver du temps de parole
la go class sur saint-jacques votre
centre de l'utopie c'est ça qui vous
tient que oui alors du coup mais je vais
aller rapidement je vais commencer par
dire quand même quand on se place pas
forcément d'allergiques d'attractivité
compétitivité lui des territoires les
uns par rapport aux autres et qu'on
considère qu'ils vous faire besançon
pour et par ses habitants donc la
question n'est pas tellement de savoir
comment besançon va rayonner jusqu'à
strasbourg où je ne sais où la question
est de savoir comment avoir une ville
qui correspond à la vie des habitants et
on considère que en en faisant de
besançon et je vais faire la transition
avec la partie suivante en faisant de
besançon un modèle de deux villes en
transition
ça peut vraiment par contre pour le coup
ramené de l'attractivité et qu'on a les
moyens à besançon d'être d'être sur
quelque chose qui peut vraiment être
très innovant et d'anticiper clairement
une quelque chose qui va nous arriver
dessus quoi qu'on en dise c'est à dire
le réchauffement climatique donc d'avoir
d'être sur une ville modèle ci merci
merci d'aller produire si j'ai une ville
modèle à ce niveau-là et du coude en
ouvrant par les combats on va reparler
de doux justement biologique transports
et mobilité une cité l'utopie qui met en
valeur un autre patrimoine et matrimoine
de besançon qui est celui des luttes
sociales de fourier au lit pas la rodia
settat et on veut aussi un centre
national des low tech
en se basant sur le savoir faire
industriel de besoins low-tech qu'il
faut expliquer en fait c'est des
technologies résilient d'encre est
valable c'est à dire d'avoir un centre
d'innovation fois la technologie du
futur
alors on va passer maintenant à
l'écologie je ne pouvais pas ne pas
commencer cette partie avec anne vignot
puisque ce thème est très présent donc
dans la campagne et c'est la première
fois que les verts se trouve à la tête
d'une liste d'union de la gauche à
besançon alors comment faire de besançon
une ville écolo moi je veux du concret
et du chiffre et s'il vous plaît et bien
c'est très simple
déjà si on va subsister c'est ça on va
prendre les choses l'une après l'autre
la question de la mobilité on sait que
c'est fondamental c'est un problème de
gaz à effet de serre c'est un problème
de pollution de l'air c'est un peu un
problème de bruit etc
et donc si on veut aller sur un
territoire résilient qui est en capacité
de répondre à des problématiques
environnementales et bien le transport
c'est fondamental donc nous avons décidé
que le samedi les transports en commun
seraient gratuits ça permet aux familles
d'explorer justement ce moyen de
mobilité
nous avons décidé de développer au moins
cinq axes de vélo express nous avons
décidé aussi que les transports en
commun serait gratuit pour les moins de
26 ans nous avons décidé aussi oui on va
s'arrêter sur les mollahs sport
justement pour demander et aux uns et
aux autres
est ce que vous êtes pour ou contre la
gratuité
alexandra cordier pour ou contre la
gratuité on est contre la gratuité parce
que la gratuité il ya toujours quelqu'un
qui la paye et quand madame vidéo
propose effectivement cette gratuité
pour les moins de 26 ans massa coûte 12
millions d'euros chaque année aux
contribuables pour les moins de 26 ans à
l'envi répondre oui 16 mois vous allez
sur le compte administratif c'est 4 5
millions sur lui il va renoncer pour
l'été polaire nous
donc pour claire arnoux sortent leur
bernos et 12 millions d'euros et pour
madame vigneault c'est 5 millions
d'euros lors des couches si je peux me
permettre de répondre
une paille c'est simple non tout le
monde attend ça j'aimerais simplement
vous savez bien que la rapide ment c'est
bien sûr la gratuité n'existe pas c'est
un juste équilibre entre le l'usager
contribuables donc si vous faites pas
payés qui est-ce qui va payer
et bah c'est le contribuable voilà et en
termes d'investissements si on n'a pas
les 25% plus coûteux fait dire ça bah si
je suis désolé quand vous tu prendrais
la part payante qui correspond entre 20
et 25 ans
c'est ça que vous mettez pas dans les
investissements alors ludovic fagots
pour ou contre la gratuité nous n'est
pour une gratuité partielle c'est à dire
aussi jusqu aux enfants à l'entrée au
lycée cet ex mannequin s'arrête pour de
maintenir les abdos jusqu'à à l'entrée
au lycée pour pouvoir permettra à ces
jeunes aussi de travailler sur le
pouvoir d'achat de leurs familles mais
aussi pour pouvoir être dans l'éducatif
et apprendre à prendre les transports
les transports en commun mais moi je
voudrais dire une chose c'est que
l'écologie aujourd'hui la transition
écologique c'est pas un parti politique
ça n'appartient pas à quelques unités
sur les 36 vous avez lancé sur la
transition écologique au départ et
madame vigneault est venu vraiment sur
cette démarche là et personne n'a le
monopole on a tous notre responsabilité
par rapport à cela
aujourd'hui en matière de transport et
de mobilité donc on a cette gratuité
jusqu'à l'entrée en lice et on a aussi
la volonté de revoir nos dessertes de
bus parce que nous avons nos secteurs de
vie qui sont excentrés du coeur
historique qui sont moins bien
desservies depuis que le tram ont ferré
sur l'un d'eux lui claire arnaud vous
vous voulez la gratuité et alexandra
cordier a déjà donné le chiffre de ce
que sam gouttes par an j'ai douze
millions d'euros we are moins de voix
l'accord à nice et je vais commencer par
par contredire ce cas une idée reçue
quand vous dites la gratuité il ya
toujours quelqu'un qui paye même et
monsieur et madame c'est le cas de tous
les droits
quand vos enfants vont à l'école
publique gratuite et laïque il ya bien
c'est de la prise en charge collective
quand l'hôpital est gratuit c'est de la
prise en charge collective et donc avec
la gratuité
il s'agit d'ouvrir un nouveau droit le
droit à la mobilité et 12 millions
d'euros
ça se trouve dans le budget notamment en
revoyant dès 2024 la délégation de
service public
ça se voit aussi par des capacités
d'autofinancement donc c'est des choses
qui sont tout à fait faisable et par
contre là où
la gratuité fait pas une politique de
transports en général c'est que si on
veut mettre en place cette gratuité
il faut aussi qu'on a un réseau de
transport en commun qu'ils soient
développés donc ça aussi on le prévoit
de la même manière on prévoit de ne pas
investir et je pense que la
responsabilité aussi c'est d'arrêter les
projets délirants comme le doublement de
la rn 57 30 à 45 millions d'euros nous
on veut mettre ça sur un réseau expresso
adresser la parole
vingt secondes pour finir votre propos
alexandra cordier vous avez commencé et
après ce sera eric alauzet qui répondra
oui quand on parle de ces masses
financières ce qu'il faut aussi préciser
aux bisontins c'est que ces 12 millions
d'euros ou ses 5 millions d'euros c'est
chaque année donc ça se multiplient
aussi par le nombre d'aînés dans un
mandat s'est multipliée par six et nous
ce qu'on propose c'est quelque chose de
plus raisonnable
effectivement c'est une mesure de
gratuité pour les enfants de moins de 11
ans pour favoriser les scolaires quatre
cent mille euros c'est beaucoup plus
raisonnables et pour les allocataires du
rsa par solidarité pour aider les plus
démunis
eric alauzet vous gratuité ou pas
gratuite et je pense que c'est pas
gratuité et qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire concrètement s'il vous plaît en
termes de transport c'est une fausse
bonne idée
je mets des guillemets c'est une
illusion c'est pas eric alauzet qui dit
ça c'est la fédération nationale des
usagers des transports
c'est le groupement des autorités qui
organisaient transports les
collectivités les régions etc
c'est une très mauvaise idée est
d'ailleurs un candidat e élevé sur votre
plateau ya quelques jours disait oui
plus de bus pas gratuite et les
écologistes n'ont jamais été
fondamentalement favorable à la gratuité
parce que ken dégradation inévitable les
écologistes mais l'inévitable du du
service et les personnes qui ne prennent
pas le but si on veut le problème c'est
les bouchons aux heures de pointe
donc on veut déplacer des personnes qui
fuient vers les transports collectifs
donc pour les dépasser il faut la marche
le vélo le covoiturage le télétravail
est aussi des bus plus performants or ça
s'est dégradé
il faut améliorer le service de bus
c'est quand on fait la gratuité si vous
habitez dans un quartier il ya pas
beaucoup de bus coup pas de bus du tout
c'est pas parce qu'on fait gratuite vous
prenez le bus c'est donc vous voulez
continuer de faire payer que sait faire
et tu le l'illusion de faire croire
qu'on va à la fois faire la gratuité et
donc perdre des recettes vous voulez
faire un peu de buzz
vous voulez mais vu plus de 200 large et
facile
quant à votre mesure où placer
systématiquement que toutes les deux me
coupe quand je c'est une manie qu'ont
concrètement vous voulez mettre quoi
c'est comme si jean 6% d'augmentation
d'impôts la gratuité
ah non mais a terminé on peut pas
laisser dire des choses de ce type c'est
la réalité
non c'est bien kiffé partenaire n'est
pas d'accord finalement qu'il était
d'accord
est-ce que là dessus alors adieu cocody
entre vous faut expliquer c'est europe
écologie les verts le parti socialiste
l'économiste génération et lescure vous
êtes tous d'accord dans votre liste
et ce contrairement à ce que dit eric
alauzet pour pour pour cette mesure là
on est tous d'accord disent pleuré
pendant le lui dise favorable à la
gratuité en septembre et s'est fait
complice il a changé c'est donc tout
mais bien sûr d'accord pas fini de
mettre d'accord je pense de lui parler
anne vignot vous répondez à ça et on
passe à la suite je voudrais juste
rappeler que les transports en commun ça
correspond effectivement un intérêt
général et l'intérêt général il est
financé comme l'école comme un certain
nombre d'autres services publics tout
sauf la sécurité et la sécurité a aussi
ça on parle pas de chez plein et bien
sûr que s'il est fort drôle ce sera bien
des docks les transports en commun ils
sont aujourd'hui gratuits puisqu'on en
tunisie ce terme là à plus de 83 %
d'accord non c'est juste pour rappeler
les chiffres parce que non mais j'ai
déjà dit ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'était la porte du musée les 12
millions d'euros qui sont considérés
pour vous comme étant payants et non pas
gratuit à partir du moment où les rangs
gratuit c'est qu'ils sont juste un
complément un ensemble du financement
des transports en commun et sept autres
partis qui est financé pour l'instant
c'est 83% comprends pas bien aujourd'hui
le jury view je refuse vraiment belle
façon et c'est très bien
j'ai revu personne n'est content pleurer
mais heureusement que besançon
aujourd'hui deviennent ce laboratoire de
logique communiste punitive
culpabilisante que vous êtes en train de
porter ses thématiques et aujourd'hui il
faut séduire les bisontines élégance
elle offre multimodale combats ont
opposé les vélos aux voitures il faut
laisser le choix aux bisontins les
algues et vous vous êtes en train de
dire interdit nous notons les gens qu'on
sait combien la mairie voyez au bout de
deux minutes de débat sur les transports
elle n'était plus pour la gratuité
maintenant ils sont pour la gratuité
mais un jour j'ai moi aussi j'ai pas
bougé d'un iota clair c'est loin d'un
clair ces contrats pour la davie qui
sont les médias jeux qui sont kong c'est
celle un budget d'investissement je
fonctionne mais j'étais à planoise toute
cette tout pendant depuis le début de
semaine je vous garantis qu'on n'est pas
on n'est pas du tout sûr des problèmes
de transe prix mais on en a pas les
débuts de l'ess de sécurité plat doit
j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur les
transports vous proposez quoi
concrètement et à quel coût
parce que ça fait déjà deux fois je vous
pose la question 6 à 15 millions d'euros
les coûts on a des tarifications parce
que les étudiants par exemple paient
deux fois plus que les salariés puisque
les salariés une contribution leurs
meilleurs donc on fera demi tarif pas de
gratuité pas de gratuité sauf très
ponctuel sur les enfants de moins de 12
ans pour faciliter les sorties scolaires
gamme pas gratuité et puis aussi pour
les seniors au ticket gratuit et donc
plus de bus donc plus de bus et plus de
moyens dire plus de secteurs plus sûrs
que ceux qui sont qui existait déjà des
années dans le réseau et des
aménagements des aménagements ceux qui
suivent donc ça coûte de l'argent j'ai
besoin de cet argent là et je ne peux
pas me permettre d'avoir une gratuité
qui fait perdre 6 à 15 millions d'euros
c'est forcément des augmentations
d'impôts et une rétrogradation du
service c'est ce qu'on observe
malheureusement parce que comme on perd
les recettes on entretient - le service
existants on dégrade le service on
renouvelle les bus moins souvent et les
exemples sont habituels et au soir une
fois les écologistes ont toujours été
opposés à cette mesure
c'est une mesure qui est poussé et bien
dans vos amis communistes sous la
pression de la france a soumises
parce que l'argent tombe du ciel
évidemment mais à la fin vous pouvez
sourire alors
enfin c'est les bisontins qui payeront
le prix à la caisse je suis à la
gratuité des transports
moi j'étais rapport à ce qu avec ce que
vient d'évoquer le député de la
république en charge des étudiants
aujourd'hui bien d'étudiants un étudiant
qui est sur paris paye 31 euros par mois
un étudiant sur le territoire bisontin
pays 28 euros par mois et donc moi je
suis d'accord avec vous avec ce que vous
avancez c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui faut
travailler aussi sur le pouvoir d'achat
de nos étudiants nous ramène vraiment
cette tarification pour les étudiants à
12 euros donc voyez on est vraiment
aussi sur quelque chose de constructif
pour le pouvoir d'achat aussi et ça
participe à cette transition écologique
on n'est pas sur le punir alors moi je
connais j'assure le cognitif bouteilles
de dix ans avant que david mal nous
rejoigne il reste très peu de temps
je voudrais que chacun d'entre vous me
donnez une mesure concrète quand vous
dites écologie environnement
on va commencer avec vous alexandra
cordier c'est quoi une mesure concrète
écologique pour besançon ces deux choses
non mais je vous ai dit une commencez
pas à tricher elle est riche à moitié
aller c'est besançon c'est resté leader
en matière de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique pour la
préservation de la biodiversité déjà
c'est rester leader et pourquoi pas
rester leader en devenant un territoire
à hydrogène claire arnoux en un mot
voilà la règle verte c'est-à-dire qu'on
réexamine tous les projets à l'aune de
ce que ce que ça coûte pour la planète
autrement dit on ne dépense pas plus que
ce que la planète est capable de
reconstituer donc ça passe par l'arrêt
d'un certain nombre de grands projets
inutiles et monsieur josé propose la
gratuité des transports en cas de pic de
pollution
donc il suffit de répondre donc voyez
jallet auteur anne vignot alors une
mesure concrète
vigneault a dit vigneault une mesure
sont prêtes avant qu'on ait monaco leur
glace vides mal jouer et vous claire
arnoux je croyais pas qu'un jour
j'allais dire ça mais taisez vous s'il
vous plaît anne vignot une mesure
concrète une mesure concrète on mettra
en place un grand giec c'est à dire un
mouvement d'un expert local
oui oui parce que nous avons la chance
d'avoir des experts sur le territoire et
qui sont prêts à nous accompagner pour
évaluer justement chacune de nos
politiques dans leur impact
environnemental
jacques richard d'éthique d'une mesure
concrète pour nous celle de cris de même
le rassemblement national s'est mise à
l'écologie non mais pas du tout nous
avons pour nous l'écologie
localisme le localisme c'est la
production la consommation et leur
traitement dans un périmètre
géographique le plus adéquat possible le
plus proche le plus proche le localisme
c'est bien ça voilà ludovic sagot une
mesure pour notre part c'est de
végétaliser nos espaces publics qui en
ont bien besoin nos écoles place de la
révolution par exemple qui est très très
minéral et bien sûr aussi équipé de
façon pragmatique nos bâtiments publics
deux récupérateurs d'énergie propre et
durable
et ça c'est vraiment de quoi des
récupérateurs des panneaux
photovoltaïques d'accord je les récupère
récupérateur d'eau excusez-moi d'eau
aussi ça en fait partie
sa grâce à deux sont des mesures qui
sont très pragmatiques et crée très
concrètes pour les patients bisontin
mais qui participent à cette transition
écologique de ses obsessions oui oui le
participent à cette transition
écologique
eric alauzet mille toit solaire avec
l'engagement des citoyens la
participation citoyenne au financement
sur des ombrières sur les parkings sur
les entreprises les toits des
entreprises sur les particuliers les
bâtiments municipaux partout et puis
aider les personnes qui sont en habitat
collectif qui trie moins bien leurs
déchets qu'on des factures élevées et là
on conjugue l'écologie le social à mieux
trier un travail d'accompagnement très
très fort avec eux ils vont contribuer à
améliorer le tri on est déjà très bon à
besançon mais pas trop bon dans le
collectif et le collectif public en
particulier et donc on va améliorer leur
pouvoir d'achat en même temps qu'ils
vont mieux contribuer à l'amélioration
de la question écologique
maintenant nous accueillons david mal
donc david de mal rédacteur en chef de
france bleu besançon je vous laisse vous
installer c'est à lui maintenant que je
vous confie mesdames et messieurs allez
david qu'est ce que vous avez retenu de
ces premières on va dire allez 50
minutes de débat un des moments
savoureux et croustillant d'abord le
débat ça recommençait à 21h06 mais c'est
à 21h13 qu'on a eu cette première
proposition choc de jean philippe
allenbach qui n'est pas là mais qui a
quand même rappelé qu'il voulait offrir
des chaises à france 3 c'est la première
marque et qu'on est très grand khan un
des promus la parole à des gens qui nous
critiquent très vertement et donc
c'était la production de jean philippe
allenbach d'abord dans un sourire puis
après on a eu ce moment très surprenant
où il fallait être un spécialiste de
l'armement pour savoir qui
parlait de 6 à war 22 ou de 38 spécial
c'est alexandra cordier qui nous a parlé
d'avoir un film d'alain delon c'était le
moment sécurité presque les experts on a
eu aussi droit à quelques échanges
intéressants comme ou ses punchlines
qu'on imaginait dans le gigot le bingo
des municipales ce qu'ils avaient devant
leur télévision préparé des petites
cases à cocher sur toutes les phrases
qu'on attendait et bien c'est arrivé à
21h24 avec vous ludovic fagots on
n'attrape pas les délinquants avec des
filets à papillons
celle ci c'était magique la première
fois entre autres au moment où il a déjà
raté sa blague il a déserté des motifs
parce que c'est vraiment un cas concret
et c'est vraiment un débat qui peut y
avoir et des philosophies différentes
votre mandant cette phrase du mariage de
la carpe et du lapin c'est vous qui
l'avez prononcé eric alauzet en parlant
de la liste des vignaux fois donc autre
autre expression pour parler de la liste
d'alain vigneault le laboratoire de
l'écologie communiste punitive ça c'est
votre expression ludovic fagots et puis
à 21h46 il ya eu ce match le match
homme/femme celui qu'on attendait plus
les hommes d'un côté les femmes de
l'autre quand eric alauzet s'est plaint
d'être coupé systématiquement par les
femmes et là on a vu les femmes d'un
côté réagi honduras est pas possible eh
bien si c'est arrivé dans ce moment de
débat maintenant vous posez vos
questions dispositif venu pour ça
exactement je vais aux questions à
jacques rivière des ti quand vous nous
avez parlé d'un nouveau palais des
congrès cinquante mille mètres carrés à
l'allemande
c'est quoi à l'allemande et ben écoute
et l'allemande cessé au coeur des
mobilités que là où je connais je
connais quelques grandes à vous aller à
munich il ya un merveilleux palais des
congrès vous allez par exemple à milan
aussi à l'italienne ou à l'abandon
bah je pense pas moi mais vous avez un
groupe allait un grand palais des
congrès où le train arrive ou les
autoroutes arrive au milieu des
connexions et au milieu des mobilités
parce que c'est important
vous faites pas vous faites pas une un
équipement public où les gens ne peuvent
pas se rendre où les gens peuvent pas se
stationner ou les gens ne peuvent pas
arriver tout simplement et d'autres
questions oui qui fait référence à ce
que vous avez dit ludovic fagots en
accusant à demi mot eric alauzet d'avoir
tout copier sur votre programme que
''pour citadelle c'était quand même
nettement mieux que le projet
au thème ça veut dire que vous
reconnaissez à votre concurrent eric
alizés d'avoir un peu les mêmes illégaux
si vous voulez sur le projet pour sida
des longs la porte est déjà depuis
depuis six ans on a parlé régulièrement
au sein de ce conseil municipal et je
n'ai pas entendu en tout cas les cons
les conseillers municipaux de la
majorité appuyer sur le bouton et se
prononcer favorablement par rapport à
cette dimension touristique que l'on
veut donner aujourd'hui au territoire
bisontins et grands bisontin donc c'est
pour ça que ça m'interroge et ça
m'interpelle c'est pour ça que j'ai pu
vous dire quant à leur bain cie que la
voûte de la dir est un peu pâle par
rapport si vous avez des copiés vous
devriez toujours pas ce que c'est
vraiment quelque chose dans lequel on
croit et comporte aujourd'hui et nous on
change pas d'avis une question pour anne
vignot parce que vous nous avez un peu
perdu sur l'attractivité vous avez
brossé différents sujets mais au final
concrètement vous faites quoi pour
rendre besançon attractive vidéo non non
nous on retravaille déjà avec les
entreprises
parce que c'est quand même un élément
important de travailler avec les
entreprises et les entreprises ont
besoin d'avoir une ville où leurs
employés sont sont bien donc il faut
travailler aussi les équipements les
crèches la cantine les écoles il faut
aussi avoir des grands projets grandeur
nature on partira sur bien sûr ce
patrimoine naturel qui peut être un
booster pour le l'activité touristique
très longtemps on est on est passé à
côté du tourisme à besançon on a une
très belle ville renaissance et on est à
côté
donc on a énormément de patrimoine
souvent s'intéresse essentiellement à la
citadelle
on a besoin aussi d'avoir une ville qui
est attractive parce que on a un tissu
culturel extrêmement foisonnant donc
c'est ce tissu culturel foisonnant il a
envie de monter un très grand projet
ensemble à vide à une autre question à
un autre candidat pour claire arnoux
parce qu'en fait pour clara donc un peu
aussi pour tous les autres candidats
vous avez tous parlé de la gratuité des
transports mais pas en pasant d'entre
vous n'a fait allusion au fait que ce
n'était pas seulement le maire ou la
maire de besançon qui ne devrait
trancher cette question mais elle
devrait être abordé avec les autres élus
de l'agglomération que les rares nous
est ce que vous vous dites oui ça sera
pas simple et on devra convaincre les
élus de l'agglo pour porter notre projet
de gratuité totale
ah ben ça sera pas simple ça c'est sûr
et par contre
grosse différence trois mois les élus
précédent c'est que moi j'ai pas validé
les transferts de compétences à
l'intercommunalité métier et cuneo pour
faire avec il ya quand même
excusez moi je termine il ya quand même
une problématique ça c'est clair
démocratiques de base à dave à ce que
les gens votent dans des communes et que
l'essentiel des décisions se prennent à
l'intercommunalité et ça c'est un
problème démocratique
oui j'aimerais bien en main oui j'ai re
mise en place du référendum d'initiative
citoyenne notamment parce qu'il ya un
problème démocratique et féerique
on n'a pas validé j'aimerais bien vous
entend justement c'est sur cette
question de l'agglomération n'a pas eu
le temps mais souvent sur l'antenne de
france bleu on a eu l'occasion de le
dire je pour ça que c'est important que
pendant cette élection municipale on
parle des projets d'agglomération mais
aussi qu'on soit en lien avec les élus
de la périphérie
c'est ce que je fais moi en tout cas
c'est à dire que les et de la périphérie
me parlent de leurs projets je le parle
de mes projets se dire qu'on anticipe
déjà ce qui pourra se passer ce qui
pourra se faire il faut sentir un peu un
peu des choses et pas partir à
l'aveuglette la fleur au fusil en
annonçant des choses qui financièrement
ne tiennent pas la route comme la
gratuité des transports ou ou d'autres
projets dithyrambique et donc moi j'ai
pris ses précautions là quand j'ai fait
mon projet de tram-train et coûte 2
millions d'euros sur des services
supplémentaires sur le ticket coûte 2
millions d'euros madame pinault ce sont
des services supplémentaires ce ne sont
pas des travaux d'investissement
j'ai pris soin d'aller discuter avec les
certain nombre d'élus de la périphérie
eux me parlent de leur projet aussi or
certains elle est socialement hors sol
et mettre leur projet comme avis poser
au milieu de nulle part est encore une
minute trente à une question pour vous
alexandre accordez vous nous avez parlé
cette fois ci du stadium vélodrome
il a changé votre projet jusqu'à présent
on avait entendu parler d'un vélodrome
stadium vélodrome
il faut imaginer autre chose ce soir non
on a toujours parlé d'un nouvel
équipement sportif multisports et
culturels
donc il y aura dedans à vélodrome
couvert mais ce grand équipement pourra
également accueillir d'autres
configurations sportive donc le basket
le hand de tir à l'arc est ce qu'on veut
avec cet équipement qui a été implantée
au coeur du campus de la bouloie c'est
offrir justement à tous les bisontins de
pratiquer leur sport parce
qu'aujourd'hui aussi pas mal de
problèmes de locaux 1 chez vous le monde
par le vélodrome qui va être construit
bientôt dans le centre-bretagne ses 12
millions d'euros le vôtre il coûtera
combien voilà la fourchette vous l'avez
donné c'est entre 12 et 15 millions
d'euros c'est une belle
cette déjà pour 2 millions oui c'est une
estimation très bien merci beaucoup
david
merci pour votre participation alors il
reste maintenant un peu plus de quatre
minutes dans cette émission on a promis
aux invités candidat donc à cette
municipale à besançon d'avoir 30
secondes chacun pour conclure leurs
propos pour conclure le débat de manière
propre et donc c'est anne vignot qui
ouvre le bal
allez-y 30 secondes top chrono et bien
voilà nous besoin sont par nature on a
une liste qui porte très fortement la
volonté de transformer la ville de
besançon transformer ces rendre active
une ville qui n'était pas encore
incapable d'être allé sur les métiers
d'avenir sur l'urbanisme d'avenir sur
les problématiques de biodiversité et la
question du climat est aujourd'hui
l'écologie lcc consolidé parce qu'elle
s'est appuyée sur un rassemblement
rassemblement de lac-simon moyens oh
merci beaucoup
eric alauzet 30 secondes pour vous aussi
finalement c'est mon métier de médecin
qui illustre à la fois ce que je suis et
ce que je veux pour cette ville de
besançon un médecin humaniste pour une
ville fraternelle un médecin praticien à
la recherche des choses concrètes
pratiques pas des discours des choses
qui marchent les besoins de répondre à
mes patients immédiatement par leur
promettre un médicament dans dix ans un
médecin écologistes parce que je me suis
intéressé très tôt aux impacts de la de
la société sur notre santé un médecin
entrepreneurs parce que médecin libéral
est aussi entrepreneur parce que à des
précurseurs de l'écologie sur besançon
il a 30 ans à une époque où ce n'était
pas facile et je termine en disant
floués
c'est fini désolé on dirige le lien que
j'avais voilà tant pis tant pis voila
voila merci beaucoup mais alexandra
cordier c'est à vous je je je me suis
edf qu'à un moment donné vous vous
intéressez aux bisons parlez vous parlez
de votre conclusion s'il vous plaît ce
qui m'intéresse moi ce sont les bisons
temps avec les listes ensemble notre
projet on a conçu notre projet et notre
liste avec les bisons temps et pour eux
donc je pense qu un maire doit être
rassembleur mais doit être la mère en
tout cas où le maire de tous les bisons
temps et moi je m'engage à être le
porte-parole des bisontins et à faire en
sorte qu'ils soient mieux représentés
claire arnaud vos trente secondes très
bien donc en fait on en a très peu parlé
mais on va arriver dans une période qui
va critique pour l'humanité en général à
besançon en particulier avec des pics de
canicule qui on est plus important et
donc la transition écologique est une
nécessité et nous on lit ça à l'écologie
populaire à la solidarité parce qu'on a
besoin que tout le monde se mette à ce
travail là et donc on peut pas avoir un
tel taux de pauvreté à besançon qu'un
sujet le social cas pas du tout a été
abordé
et on lit ça aussi à l'implication
citoyenne parce que de nouveaux une
ville en transition c'est une ville qui
doit impliquer tout le monde d'où le
fait qu'on veut renouveler la démocratie
avec le référendum d'initiative suel le
référendum accord assez bon et merci
tout plein li 2vic fagots vous savez
tous les représentants qui sont ici
autour de la table sont issus de la
majorité sortante et moi je ne fais pas
partie de leur cerveau et je ne fais pas
partie de l'immeuble
il avait le pouvoir de changer les
choses mais ils ne l'ont pas fait qu'ils
ont échoué et en plus ils sont des
fausses et besançon a rendez vous
aujourd'hui avec l'avenir je ne serai
pas le maire d'un clan je serais
vraiment le maire des bisontines et des
bisontins parce que nous avons des
talents des talents à faire valoir et je
souhaite vraiment que besançon soit
enfin la ville de tous les possibles et
les bisontins et les bisontines
attendent ce changement et je remettrai
vraiment en oeuvre et de la vie dans la
ville avec l'ensemble de mon équipe
jacques rétiaire des ti bécaud
témoignera pas de concept fumeux pour
nous c'est la sécurité avec du concret
20 millions d'euros l'armure de la
police municipale enfin tout ce qu'on a
pu développer jusqu'à maintenant de la
proximité donc au plus près des
préoccupations des bisontins c'est c'est
un conseil municipal délocaliser dans
chacun des quartiers une fois par an du
concret toujours est du localisme et
bien évidemment du localisme dans
l'alimentation est bien évidemment
redonner des places de crèches de 2 dans
les cantines à aux élèves bisontin parce
que même ça on n'en a pas parlé voyez
c'est quand même étonnant donc pour nous
du concret merci beaucoup
alors je vous laisse maintenant lire le
nom des neuf listes présentes à à
besançon pour dimanche pour le premier
tour le 15 mars
d'autres soirées donc va se poursuivre
avec vesoul alors je tiens à remercier
bien sûr mesdames et messieurs d'avoir
participé merci également à david mal de
france bleu besançon
alors certains d'entre vous les
qualifiés pour le deuxième tour se
retrouveront ici mercredi prochain même
lieu même heure et c'est jérémy
chevreuil qui animera le débat
l'entre-deux tours il me reste à vous
dire donc que notre soirée spéciale
élections municipales se poursuit avec
cette fois ci la ville de vesoul et
quatre invités sur le plateau
ce débat a été enregistré cet après midi
allez on se retrouve nous tout de suite
[Musique]